One batch
Two batch
Penny and Dime
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
fresh off all that new daredevil born again season
one footage recently and Jon Bernthal coming back
as his version of Punisher during season one of that,
We just learned about Marvel's larger plans to do
revivals and new seasons of a bunch of other TV shows
starting with some of the Netflix defenders characters.
Daredevil apparently is just the beginning.
it was just reported recently.
Punisher is supposed
to get a new season of his own show.
A lot of you've been asking for that,
like give Punisher season three.
And you know how Marvel is.
I really can't say anything anyway.
But I care about Frank deeply.
And no matter how much Frank grows, he's
always going to be the same.
So we'll break it all down.
And what their plans were for Punisher season three
when it was still on Netflix
because the person who did the Punisher Netflix series
is essentially doing Daredevil Born Again.
Now, like Kevin Feige hired the Punisher people
to come back and make Daredevil Born again.
so it is no coincidence that there's
all this Punisher stuff happening with Jon Bernthal
as version of the character.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We have the Deadpool
three trailer coming in a couple of days.
There's a bunch of Super Bowl trailers.
Of course, I will do videos for everything.
I literally just did a much bigger video
for all the Daredevil Born Again
Episode one footage
we just got with Daredevil versus Bullseye.
Both of them in their new
comic book suits is just the beginning.
we've been talking about this since the Echo episodes
earlier this year because Marvel officially canonized
all the old Netflix defenders shows Punisher
technically wasn't on the Defenders.
He didn't show up during that series,
but he's included in the larger
Marvel Netflix umbrella characters of shows,
this is like Kevin Feige's Chief
Lieutenant that runs most of Marvel television
under Marvel Studios.
He was talking about Canonize,
seeing all the Marvel Netflix stuff.
ba. Basically everybody is slowly coming back,
starting with Daredevil Kingpin during Spider-Man.
No Way Home, Hawkeye, Echo, Bullseye just came back
and all these new scenes from Daredevil Born Again
Episode one and it is the version of Bullseye
from the Daredevil Netflix series.
we learned that Jon Bernthal is version of the Punisher
from the Netflix series
has a major story arc during Daredevil born again
season one.
I'll get into what that is in the second.
we also heard about Krysten Ritter
coming back as her version of Jessica Jones.
She literally just posted a picture of herself
teasing her return again
when all these daredevil scenes were dropping recently.
Notice she's still wearing the shirt
from the Jessica Jones Netflix series.
They're very clearly teasing with her caption,
I just did a video about them bringing back
a couple versions of Iron Fist in new TV series,
like they're slowly folding
in basically all these characters.
but probably the bigger news.
This past week we learned Marvel has a more formal plan
to revive a bunch more TV shows,
not just the Netflix Marvel shows,
but other TV shows made before Kevin Feige and Marvel
Studios took over production on all these
probably the most relevant example of that is X-Men,
the Animated series, X-Men
the animated series is essentially becoming X-Men 97.
That's going to air before Deadpool
three comes out to sort of set up
the idea of mutants X-Men coming back to the MCU.
Wish, you get a trailer for that pretty soon
because they made it all shiny and nice.
But essentially it's like the next season of X-Men
Animated Series under a different title,
the same way that Daredevil Born Again
is Daredevil Season
four, under a slightly different title
from the Netflix series
And apparently it's the same idea with Jon Bernthal
as version of The Punisher.
It would basically be a different version
of what they originally intended to do
for Punisher Season three when it was still on Netflix.
some of you probably realize this,
but essentially they're kind of doing what they did
during the Netflix series with all these characters do.
Like you start with Daredevil,
then you slowly start cameo ing,
crossing over other defenders
characters on his show, other shows.
Then they all go off to their own spinoff TV shows.
Now they're basically doing it again
under the Marvel Studios banner
on Disney Plus, Punisher being very relevant to this
because he's started on Daredevil Season two,
then went on to Punisher season one.
Now the person who made the Punisher Netflix series
was just brought back by Kevin Feige to make Daredevil
Born Again with a bunch of the Netflix crew
like the Fight Coordinators, other creatives,
there's going to be a huge Punisher arc during season
one of Daredevil born again.
It only makes sense.
It's in preparation for Punisher
getting a new season of his own series now.
It would be a slightly shortened season.
It wouldn't be the same number of episodes as Daredevil
Born Again, or is the original Punisher series
because they used to get 10 to 13 episodes
per season in no idea what the title would be because,
for instance, they didn't call Daredevil
Born Again Daredevil Season four,
even though that's kind of what it is.
And this would be punished for season three.
So they give it some other title
like The Punisher dropping the Marvel ahead of it,
or they call it like Punisher.
Max That'd be a funny dig at HBO. Max it.
It would be a cool reference to the comics.
the only problem there with Punisher
with using some of his comic book titles
is that most of his comic book titles
go way too hard for a Disney Plus.
The upside, though, is that they can still do it.
TV-MA like Echo was TV-MA what am I Criticisms
there, though, is that
Echo didn't really need the TV-MA rating
because it was actually pretty tame relative
to like the Marvel Netflix series like Punisher.
Netflix went way harder.
Daredevil, Netflix, pretty much all the Marvel
Netflix series went way harder.
there's still a question as to whether or not Daredevil
Born Again is also going to be TV-MA.
But this is what Karen Page's face
looked like in the scenes that they were filming with
Daredevil versus Bullseye. Feisty.
So if Blood is covering her face,
then maybe it will also be TV-MA,
Rhino Marvel's plan for bringing Back
Jon Bernthal as Punisher
is coming back during Daredevil born again season one,
he did not get snapped.
He spent the five year time jump basically
doing the same thing that Hawkeye Ronin, Daredevil did,
going into overdrive, taking out the worst of the worst
criminals that did not get snapped.
the only real difference between Punisher, Daredevil
and Hawkeye is that unlike Hawkeye,
they stay local to New York City during that period.
Hawkeye was going all over the world,
taking out the mob.
Other big villains who survived the snap
in other parts of the planet.
really good example.
This is all these daredevil versus echo
fight scenes were from that five year time jump period.
So you have to picture when that's happening.
Kingpin also had been released from jail
where he'd gone after Daredevil Season three.
while he's rebuilding his power base,
the cops basically let him do whatever he wants.
He's already pretty powerful at this point
in the five year time jump.
you had to picture Punisher
going crazy, left and right, killing all the worst
criminals around New York City.
While this is happening with kingpin and Daredevil,
both kind of doing their own thing,
two, respectively,
they probably crossed paths a couple times.
It'd be hard
not to with half the number of people in the area.
Kingpin did reference Daredevil
during that five year time jump.
He made it sound like Daredevil kept coming after him.
His men many times during that period,
and he treated it like clockwork.
Like he wasn't surprised
that Echo had a fight with him.
He was more impressed that she survived the fight.
Like, yeah, she did pretty good.
You survived, Punisher and Kingpin's relationship
would also be similar.
Most of this goes back to their prison fight
where they have it out the same way
Daredevil and Kingpin eventually did.
They have a similar relationship?
Punisher basically told him he would kill him.
Kingpin kind of told him the same thing
to the whole difference between Punisher and Daredevil
is that Punisher just doesn't care about putting
Kingpin in prison, like doing things aboveboard.
He is out killing Kingpin's men left and right
dismantle his organization the old fashioned way.
then post blip after Avengers endgame.
Everybody comes back.
We have the events in Spider-Man, No way home.
Hawkeye Echo Kingpin gets the idea to run
for mayor of New York City and seize his opportunity
to get rid of Punisher, Daredevil, Spider-Man Bullseye
pretty much all the heroes and any of the villains
the Kingpin does not like in the New York City area
or anybody that's giving him grief just in general.
Just Brandon is a vigilante, dangerous.
Look at all the people that are killing.
We need to lock them up, basically
running for mayor on an anti vigilante campaign.
For example, one of the story arcs they're adapting
from the comics is the recent news villain.
this is a scene of him during Daredevil Born again
episode one.
Under Kingpin's definition,
he'd be branded as another dangerous vigilante
that needed to be locked up end, in the comics,
one of the problems for Daredevil, the other heroes,
is that Muse's inspired to go after corrupt
New York City police, judges, politicians.
But he's even more hardcore than Punisher
does things in a really gruesome way,
killing a ton of people, creating these art murals,
using their bodies in in a lot of his crime scenes,
he draws references to the Punisher
specifically like other vigilantes in this WTF art.
So you had to imagine muse here
during daredevil born again doing something similar
and then Kingpin who's running for mayor,
talking about getting rid of all the dangerous people
in New York City, dangerous vigilantes
pointing at examples like Muse here
and using it as a way to go after Punisher,
Daredevil, Spiderman, all these other vigilantes.
giving him the excuse
that he was looking for This whole time.
in as mayor, he has the resources and the ability
and the justification to hire villains
to do his dirty work.
you have to imagine him hiring Spider-Man
villains, for instance, who are currently locked up.
if he's going to be in Spider-Man four,
he should be the one to hire the Sinister
Six to go after Spider-Man.
Like he should just hire a bunch of Spider-Man villains
to get rid of all vigilantes,
and they just happen to go after Spider-Man.
another good example during Daredevil born again
is the White Tiger character from the comics
is going to be a big person during the season.
This is what he's going to look like.
During episode one.
Kingpin Pride tries to make an example of him
to when the season picks up.
Punisher was originally supposed
to be going after corrupt cops,
like the ones
helping Kingpin here during the five year time jump.
That might change a little bit,
but the concept is still the same.
Kingpin uses his campaign is an excuse
to get rid of Punisher and people like Punisher.
It sounds like that's what leads to him
in Daredevil, teaming up again,
helping each other at night,
fight Kingpin's henchmen other villains in by day.
Matt Murdock.
The really good lawyer, helps out
Frank Castle citizen stay out of serious jail time,
or if he does have to go to jail,
help him as much as he can.
Then Punisher leaves, goes off to his solo series.
What would essentially be Punisher Season three
like a continuation of the Punisher Netflix series
Originally, The Punisher Netflix showrunner says Season
three
would have brought Mike Rowe back
because he sat out Season two.
Evan Moss Bachrach, though, is supposed to be playing
the brand new version of the thing in that Fantastic
Four movie, so he's kind of off the table
unless they recast the micro character.
he also said
Punisher would have become more of a comic book
Punisher persona, going after criminals
full time on the regular, like wearing the Punisher
logo all the time instead of laying low
like he was when Season two picked up.
season two was more about him
protecting Amy, stopping Jigsaw.
He had actively been trying to avoid going on
any larger crusades
to stop crime in the New York City area.
That changed in the season two finale.
that last moment of him going out to the gang
in the middle of their deal was a teaser
for what Season three would have felt like with him
wearing the Punisher Skull logo full time
doing stuff like this on the regular in the episodes.
and because he would have been back in New York City,
there would have been
more crossover with Daredevil,
the other Defenders characters again,
and now they're kind of doing a version of that already
during Daredevil Born Again.
Like there's kind of continuing that storyline.
so it sounds like they do a new season of The Punisher.
They just introduce more characters
from the Punisher Comics and just spin off
some of the plot that they've set up
through Echo and Daredevil, Born again.
They're couple big Punisher villains like Barracuda,
Nick Cavell,
mostly mob related characters
that they haven't done yet.
I think there was even a Punisher fan film
that used the Nick novella character a while ago.
But a really good example of this phenomenon
is during the Echo Post-Credits scene,
Kingpin says he wants a meeting
with the heads of all the major families
working for him to discuss what's going on.
you can actually just have Punisher going after all
the heads of those families During his own series.
Let me know in the comments.
What do you want Punisher to be doing?
If he gets a brand new season of his own show?
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up, though.
So if we hear any more about other Marvel Netflix
characters coming back or other Netflix characters
getting their own solo series like doing a new Jessica
Jones season, of course I'll do videos for that
and we should get that X-Men 97 trailer
after the Deadpool three trailer pretty soon.
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of that
because there's a bunch of really big stuff coming up
Click here for that brand new daredevil born again
Episode 1 teaser With all that brand new footage
and click here from a new Deadpool 3 video
and learn why he destroys the Marvel Universe
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!